PAUL MAURICE WAS BEHIND THE
BENCH AND THE
HALF FULL TONIGHT AND A FULLITHE
NOW STARTING OUT H H IS
HE ZONE D
THAT IS ONE OUT STILL
AND NOW KANE TO HOLD IT IN.
THIS IS JONES.
THE STICK OF McCABE. WILL COMPLN
THAT HE HAD THROWN HIS STICK
FOLLOWING THE SAVE AND HE MIGHT
V
PERFETTI LIFTING IT UP AND OUT.O
FLIP IT OUT AND NOW THE
COUNTERATTACK BY THE BLACKHAWKS
BELOW THE GOAL
JACCOB SLAVIN, THE DEFENDER IN
CAROLINA, PLA
BACK U AT 6:00 EASTERN,
THIS HERE.IC.
>> Greg: AND WINNIPEG GOING OFF
THERE, ON A QUICK UP, THERE BY
MURPHY,
DeMELO, CHIPS IT.
HAD A PAIR IN THE G TAKING
A SHOT, ANOTHER SHOT AT
HELLEBUYCK AND HE WILL GLOVE IT
>> Greg: Wg: THAT IS WHAT I WAS
TALKING ABOUT, RIGHT THERE, THAN
AT THEMORRISSEY TO STANLEY AND T
THERE.
DOWN. COPP, DROPPING IT
BACK.
AND HERE,
HAS TO BAC IS HELLEBUYCK NOW
OUT TO STOP
THIS TIME McCABE AROUND MORRISS,
TAKING A SHOT AND NOW THE TAPE E
AND THEN THE EMPTY-NETTER
AFTERWARDS AND THE